a lot of white people up front this is
boxing out the Indians you made it
though this swaggy [__] when
does your mixtape come out yo
what do you do for a living
you're not a lawyer I trust ever bro I'm
gonna be honest muscle that you go to
the same one is better Call Saul
this is your girl right here I can tell
cause she's so happy every time I make
funny when I get on your hair the joy
her whole soul lit up how long have you
been together that you kept this hair
just to piss her off because I knew it I
knew he didn't like this haircut but
he's just like you know what I'm tired
of this criticizing everything about me
I'm gonna make my hair look like
Hiroshima then what the [__] you got to
say you guys married engaged anything
God damn Indian girls don't give a [__]
about you so funny she's embarrassing
the [__] out of this guy laughing every
time I make fun of him still wants to
marry him ain't that funny